[Music]
now it's time for another [ __ ]
the Whitney Houston the intro Milligan
this point should pop out your piano
make a little junior I'm late
he won't do it if he's told you gotta
feel it yeah it's been a while it is
titled ADA for canceling a wedding my
parents are paying for and not folding
reimbursing them they say I want them
either they might have my [ __ ] for
canceling a wedding my parents are
paying for and not fully reimbursing
that yes yeah that's dealing you stupid
[ __ ] [ __ ] I want to hear it first though
cuz what if I don't know what
circumstance is it okay in their opinion
I think um if the couple never wanted to
hold a wedding but the parents insisted
and they're like oh I want to hold this
wedding for you and then like maybe a
disaster happen at the wedding and like
the parents felt like the wedding didn't
live up to the experts but the wedding
didn't go through and our now demanded
like oh you need to pay us back because
we paid for this waiting for you and
it's like yo we didn't want this wedding
in the first place but you forced it
upon us and so you went out of your way
to pay for it but the wedding didn't
even go through cuz they canceled oh
that's all stretch I know that's gonna
be them finally I thought was gonna be
like hey we put a deposit we spent some
money they're not giving us back and we
can't remember the full amount doesn't
reverse anything I'll tell you guys the
story here we go so it says basically
this is a big [ __ ] mess basically
basically okay my fear my fiance and I I
know I see in Minnesota my fiance
but Beyonce and I were supposed to get
married in the spring but due to the
pandemic we had to postpone our venue
allowed us to move our date to September
for a small fee and we very naively in
retrospect agreed to do it because we
thought that things would be back to
normal by now obviously they aren't my
fiance and I kept going back and forth
on what to do and after a lot of tears
and debate we decided to cancel the
wedding completely and elope we don't
think is the safest idea to have a
wedding right now and we don't have the
energy to keep postponing and replanting
everything and to be completely honest
we'd rather have no wedding at all than
a wedding with only a quarter of our
guests where everyone has to wear masks
and social distance didn't even think
about that so here's a problem my
parents gave us about $20,000 for the
wedding last year we put towards our
major vendors including our venue we
should be able to get some partial
deposits back like the photographer and
the DJ which are willing to work with us
at least
but our venue is being extremely
stubborn and says they won't refund us
because our state is allowing weddings
at this time we have a consultation with
an attorney next week and are going to
see what our options are but I'm not
confident we're going to be able to get
anything back my parents had been
expecting us to move forward with the
rescheduled September wedding and now
that we've canceled
they're super pissed off and we and are
demanding we reimburse them for the
money they gave us we told them we can
give them back the final payments we
didn't have we hadn't made yet and the
refunds we will get which is about
$8,000 but the rest of the money is tied
up in the venue and we're unlikely to
see it again we said they need to take
this up with the venue not with us they
won't accept this and insist it's ours
responsibility to pay them back even if
it has to be through a repayment plan
over the next few years
fiancé and I are frustrated because
we're trying to do the right thing for
our guests safety and we don't feel we
should be financially financially
penalized for it we feel terrible that
my parents are losing so much money but
it isn't our fault that our venue is
being so unreasonable and they were the
ones who want who were in
did on paying in the first place am I
the [ __ ] I don't think you know how
to solve a problem if yeah I don't think
they're [ __ ] but cuz well here's a
thing like I don't know how their family
operates but in my family when you give
you give and you don't expect anything
back you know and then you try to just
do things and then and then if you feel
bad enough in the future you surprise
them with the 20 grand and you give it
back cuz you didn't go through with it
but it's their choice not to go through
with it the venue's being so [ __ ]
hard and they're gonna just lose the
money they're choosing the option of
just losing the money and not going
through with it even if the venue is
allowing it yeah cuz it's like you do
have the option of just going through
and I have the money why don't you just
have the wedding cuz they don't have the
energy to do right so dirt to me it's
almost like well okay you're not getting
your picture-perfect wedding and you're
not willing to compromise then you need
to do your work and go after that money
and you need to go harder you can't tell
you take it up with them exactly oh so
disrespectful when I read that I was
like but you were the one who signed the
contract not your parents how are they
gonna be going up in there but and if
parents given option like a payment plan
and stuff like that cuz I get it like
but asking for money back from your kids
is just though to me it's a it's hard
thing well I mean it's [ __ ] weird
totally weird but I could understand for
example like um well my my parents
wanted to help my sister out when she
got married like my parents don't really
have a lot of money so what they do they
refinance the house for the second time
yeah you know in order to get somebody
just to help with the wedding so I
totally understand that like if the
wedding still didn't especially I don't
know what they are but even for like
let's say like an Asian culture family
like the weddings really not even for
like the people it's like for like the
family yeah you know what I'm saying
it's like to bring the whole family and
fly them from whichever place and I kind
of have this proud no more it's like
look I married off my son or my daughter
or whatever so I think that there are
like variables that might at least be
like look they it's possible to be like
hey the wedding didn't happen didn't
give me give me great to have our money
back you know understand because it
might have been from a very strenuous
player but I mean again that's my
personal experience in my understanding
of it but yeah like Joe said they chose
not to
do with the wedding the virus sucks for
everybody the virus left for the venue
even even though the venue's being
difficult it's a realistic [ __ ] time for
a lot of people so it's like you know if
if the people who are supposed to be
gifted this wedding are like choosing
not to have the wedding then it's I
think reasonable to like come to an
agreement with the pants maybe it's not
all 20 grand maybe it's better than
payment plan maybe it's like hey can we
get you this and then hopefully we can
not worry about the rest you know but
like yeah it totally is not the parents
responsibility to go talk to the venue
do you got lazy that's that's the
[ __ ] part to me yeah that is an
[ __ ] part that sounds like a mess the
person that gifted you the money
shouldn't have to deal with the mess
that you created yeah exactly
even if the venue is being hard you
chose this [ __ ] venue you chose to do
business with these people and even if
you didn't know what kind of [ __ ]
they would be it's still your
responsibility because you chose to do
business with someone it's like if my
parents gave me money to do business
like and get into a partnership with
someone and I create a coffee shop with
them and like even though they gave me
that money to invest into this coffee
shop but this guy's [ __ ] me over like
it's still my job to get that money back
or fight for it or whatever like it's
not damn saying like when you invested
into it take it up with them like I
don't know man it just doesn't seem
right yeah yeah I mean I agree I feel
like if it's to the point where I know I
can't get that money back from the venue
I will and if my parents really need the
money back like like for sure for sure
to like demanding yeah be like let me
just set up a payment plan with you
because at this point it's gone like
it's gone and like if I'm still like
going through with idea that I just want
to elope and just have like a small
group of friends like that's the choice
that we've made right and it's like
that's the money that they gave us for
specific purpose but I'm no longer using
that money for that so to me is just
like I'll pay you back that's what I'm
cause I think in these people's shoes
they're thinking of it as more like well
it's out of our hands because the venue
won't give it back to us right I think
it's still in your hand
they can still have the wedding yeah the
choice should at least you pushing it
further
I think the mentality is more of like
well you gifted me this 20k yeah that's
really entitled yeah I think it's more
of like you gifted it to me versus
you've lent me this money with the
intent of a wedding right so if the
wedding didn't happen then there then I
think that people have to get to that
second solution stage where it's like if
something didn't work out you can't just
keep beating it with what happened in
the past all right
no one expected Coe via to happen and
then you or people probably thought it
would clear by September a lot of people
thought that it was naive but a lot of
people did think that right and then now
you're in this predicament right how do
you move forward where everyone can win
like no one thinks that way they go well
tough luck buddy
you don't do that to family you don't
tell people tough luck you go [ __ ] okay
you want the money back and it's not
really why do you need the money back if
people ask for the money back then it's
like okay they're asking for the money
back how do I get it back
instead of saying I can't get it back
the venue has it they're not giving it
to me like that's some kid [ __ ] in my
opinion like your shirt well technically
to be fair they are the kids they are
the kids but there are dots Yeah right
and at that's at the same time you
didn't have the money to have a wedding
yourself they gifted you money well they
did right like they did make it a point
to right that they were the ones who
insisted on paying in the first place
would it be a fighting Risley their
money would they be fighting if it was
their money or would they be kind of
push those in today [ __ ] they said no
I think if it was their money they
probably just would have been like [ __ ]
it and left it yeah it sounds like
they're pretty passive it sounds like
also like yo like man to [ __ ] up like
take charge and like talk to them be
like don't just accept that you'd lost
it you know that's what I do Mikey
that's why president me like like no go
get your money like don't be an idiot
well it seems like they're going forward
with a lawyer and all that but it
doesn't seem like they want to fight
like yeah like it seems like they're
tired already don't even have a water
wedding yeah if you're gonna make a post
and say like am I being the [ __ ] type
thing you know because like should I pay
my
you know understand it's like you could
be figuring out something if my parents
gave me 20 grand oh hey you want a car
right I'm like yeah I need a car hey we
want a paper you think dude you don't
have to pay for this car no I'm gonna
buy a car here's 20 grand and then I go
[ __ ] buy a bike right and I come back
thinking bit where's the [ __ ] car
it's like no I didn't buy the car give
me my money yeah exactly exactly even if
you go even if it's a kid even if you go
well like their car but then they
wouldn't give me the money back so like
I reserved the car but I got a bike
instead it's like what yeah like you got
swindled you're just like well let me
place this initial investment and then
all of a sudden it's like yeah I was
trying to be nice
yeah pay for I didn't you [ __ ]
swindle my ass what the [ __ ] give that
back to me
it's to me I think they kind of are what
were the people saying they got labeled
as the [ __ ] yeah yeah right okay good
because in the beginning I was like the
parents sound like [ __ ] for being
like you know wanting a gift back or
wanting money back but then in this the
more I think about it I'm like didn't
get the gift or anything yet they just
figured to do one yeah this one person
said they said that money was not an
unconditional gift it was given to you
explicitly for a wedding at that
location if you chose not to have a
wedding you no longer have any right to
that money true yeah have a smaller
wedding than if you do it like she
didn't want to replan if she were to
move the date again yeah you don't wanna
have mass like overwhelmed and kind of
like at the point of I'm over it
right then [ __ ] be over it okay your
parents back it's like they want to be
over it but run away from it yeah I
don't like that [ __ ] mm-hm
[Music]
[Music]